[Music]
so MKBHD here so I was talking to a
friend recently and he asked me what
phone I was using and it was a Galaxy
Note 20 Ultra sitting right in front of
me
and so I said oh nice cool so how do you
like it
and this is the moment where I have to
try to distill all of my thoughts and my
testing and my experience into like one
sentence that's easily digestible to a
you know a regular everyday person
that's not in the tech world and what
came out of my mouth was
yeah it is it's really nice but it's
also one thousand three hundred dollars
so it better be and so when I step back
to really think about it and to put
together all my thoughts for this full
review for you guys that thought really
just kept coming back to me over and
over because at this price you really
only see like the crazy first-gen
experimental folding phones or flagships
the bleeding edge absolute best that a
company has to offer and this this is a
1300 Flagship so it's got to be top of
the line at basically everything to even
consider it worth buying and the note 20
Ultra for me kind of lives up to that
first of all this is the best looking
Best Built phone Samsung has ever made
in my opinion the matte sort of soft
touch finish on the back the boxy flat
top and bottom the razor thin bezels the
chamfers that all the metal rails and
edges even this color this Mystic bronze
is not normally a look I go for it's
kind of pink from some angles but also
kinda rose gold from some other angles
but I actually kind of like it and I
like the contrast with the dark camera
bump so all the way around like I said
from the first time I picked up this
metal and Glass phone in my first
impressions video it screams quality and
with Samsung's flagships there's always
also a bunch of the little things that
also add up to make that premium feeling
experience things that we would be
nitpicking and complaining about if they
weren't here for this price but they are
here so the vibration motor is really
high quality the same ultrasonic
in-display fingerprint reader is back
here and it's pretty fast there's
wireless charging that's here reverse
wireless charging is here there's ip68
water resistance all the stuff we kind
of take for granted to be in a Samsung
Flagship but it is all here again just
no headphone jack and then I think the
two main things that make this an ultra
note are the display and the S Pen so
the display
at the risk of sounding like displaymate
is a plus plus but it is an awesome
screen it's a 6.9 inch Quad HD Super
AMOLED display it's got HDR
certification the 120 hertz refresh rate
the tiny hole punch in the top of the
middle outstanding maximum and minimum
brightness it's crispy it's great I mean
it's just a great screen but there are
believe it or not both pros and cons to
this Ultra screen the main con being it
is absolutely massive and it has curved
edges and yes I did experience
accidental touches occasionally and I
think that happened more often thanks to
the hand gymnastics that are required to
handle such a big screen like this I've
said it before and I'll say it again I'm
on the side of preferring we go back to
Flat displays but this one is not flat
but also of course having a huge display
that goes right up to the edges and a
tiny hole punch cut out I mean that
makes a pretty solid media experience
although I will say maybe my only
Hardware disappointment in this phone is
the speaker system and not that it's
problematic it's not bad at all it's
just easy to block that bottom speaker
and it is a stereo pair with the
earpiece but overall despite its Dolby
Atmos support I was unimpressed with the
actual quality or fullness of the sound
from the speakers the specs behind the
display are all high-end as you'd expect
if you didn't already know Snapdragon
a65 plus and this unit has 12 gigs of
RAM now you know and that combined with
120hz display is really everything I
want in a smartphone nowadays you've
heard me talk about high refresh rate it
makes its way to yet another Flagship
here in the note and yes I still love it
there were no problems with performance
and smoothness from my usage was great
also behind the notes display is the
same ultrasonic fingerprint reader we
saw in the s20 ultra and it's Ultra
impressive and Ultra similar to last
year's performance nothing Ultra special
here and then you got yourself a 4 500
milliamp hour battery now I'm I'm old
enough to remember when Samsung Galaxy
Note was like the the big battery phone
it was a battery champ it was the phone
that us nerds would take to CES because
it was just the battery you couldn't
kill in one day
it's not that anymore you know shocker
you can kill this 4 500 milliamp hour
battery with a giant 120 hertz display
using it all the time you can kill it
even if it's not a Quad HD but with
typical use note 20 ultra's battery is
good like it's six hours of screen on
time ending a day with 15 to 25 percent
battery left regularly good and I have
no problems with that especially when
this phone also supports 45 watt fast
charging and there's wireless charging
so it's good if you really want the
extra Next Level battery champ there are
other phones including the brother of
this phone s20 Ultra which is kind of
just like the same form factor minus the
S Pen that's a 5000 milliamp hour
battery so that's better but this is
good okay let's talk about the camera I
have a lot to say about this camera
system as you can probably imagine but
I'll try to keep it concise here first
of all this camera bump is huge it's
huge and there are other phones with big
camera bumps big cam camera systems but
something about this one just being a
straight up shelf like it's not tiered
like the s20 ultra or rounded or you
know a double shelf like some others
they don't try to hide it it's just a
big block on the back of this phone that
sticks out so much that it actually has
a tendency to gather dust in the corners
around it but I honestly don't hate it
it's like they're owning it it's a
character piece that you know maybe has
time to grow on you the rings around the
three cameras to me I think is a good
look and you do get a great array of
cameras it's the 108 megapixel standard
camera that sort of rattles a bit when
you shake it because it's so big
and then there's a 12 megapixel Ultra
wide and a 12 megapixel Periscope zoom
camera if you really do hate the camera
bump and the fact that it sticks out so
much and Wobbles like crazy when it's on
a desk you can always grab a grip case
from Channel sponsor dbrand it's
actually literally the perfect size to
get rid of the camera bump and then you
got your added protection so I'll drop a
link below if you're interested in that
if not you can live dangerously like me
and walk around with a glass phone and
no protection so how are the cameras
they are great first of all the addition
of the laser autofocus really fixed the
hunting problems the Galaxy s20 Ultra
was having with this same huge camera
module now it's not the same tracking
autofocus as a pixel but the hunting is
gone close-up subjects are no longer
problematic but what it didn't fix is
the shutter lag so there's still a
pretty noticeable delay between tapping
to take a photo and when the actual
capture happens which is kind of a
bummer if you're trying to capture fast
motion or any action type stuff or just
like trying to time a photo of a fire
truck outside hotel at 3am to not be
flaring into the lens but I will say
that with the caveat that you got to be
a little more patient and hold the
camera still and wait for the shutter
lag this camera turns out outstanding
photos in all kinds of conditions in
daylight in harsh shooting into the sun
shooting at night shooting indoors and
Outdoors this thing crushes I think you
could make an argument that it's just
above the pixel for versatility thanks
to having a really good ultrawide that's
almost as sharp as the main lens and of
course the massive zoom capabilities
that you never have to use but if you do
they're impressive still 50x isn't as
insane as 100x but it's far more than
you'll probably ever need and so you can
rest easy that anytime you need a quick
4X or 8X Zoom the photo will still be
plenty sharp the 10 megapixel selfie
camera is fairly average but acceptable
and then for video I'd put it again
right below the iPhone system thanks to
the super study mode and all the 8K
options and the faster autofocus but
really I was having most of my fun with
the main sensor and taking photos that I
think would often rival what you take
from any other phone iPhone 11 Pro pixel
4 Huawei phones this is right up there
well done Samsung on these cameras just
makes it feel like the gigantic camera
bump is more worth it are you impressed
that we got this far into a Galaxy Note
review without talking about the S Pen
yet
so the S Pen got some pretty dramatic
technical improvements in the note 20
Ultra this year mainly that the latency
is now down all the way to nine
milliseconds on this better display and
that translates to apple pencil levels
of realism and responsiveness you love
to see it you love to hear it also maybe
there's this sound now when you write
with the S Pen that actually corresponds
pretty well with how it would sound if
you were writing on like a chalkboard or
a pen on paper or something
it's it's pretty impressive but I could
also see that getting annoying to
someone who uses the S Pen like a lot so
you can turn that off but yeah
technically speaking it is a big
Improvement but the S Pen really overall
is the same thing it's been for a while
which depending on who you are is either
a fun optional accessory that comes
along with this Flagship or an
absolutely vital tool for sketching or
note taking or annotation work you may
remember from my previous reviews I'm
not the biggest S Pen person uh so for
someone like me a Galaxy Note probably
isn't the best use of money but there
are people who every year wait for the
latest Galaxy Note because this phone
represents the absolute best stylus
experience on a phone and so for those
people yeah this is it I can make this
like a an hour and a half long video if
I tried to cover all of the features
buried in Samsung software because they
absolutely pack this phone to the gills
The Edge lighting the secure folder the
wireless music sharing the air actions
the reverse wireless charging the
wireless Dex is super impressive even
Bixby routines
Bixby I mean I found there's always
something buried in here that you've
either never heard about or maybe you
knew about it but just didn't use it
because Samsung errors on the side of
shoving in too many features instead of
the other way around like trying to keep
it super simple and leaving things out
that aren't perfect it's like the
opposite of the Apple strategy and you
see that throughout using this phone
from the launcher to the camera app to
the settings and if there's any upside
to that it certainly makes you feel like
you're more getting your money's worth
but at the end of the day are you
are you getting 1 300 worth of
smartphone here
honestly that's probably pushing it I'd
say you probably aren't but the thing
about Samsung launch prices is they're
guaranteed to fall like this phone in
three or four months will most likely
cost a bit less than it does now at
launch but if there's any phone that
makes it feel like you're getting the
absolute complete package from the spec
sheet to the huge incredible display to
the build quality to the cameras to the
battery to the stylus you can't get
anywhere else
to the software
it's probably this one but I want to end
it all with this
what is a review really
well it's given your opinion on
something you've used try to figure out
if what you're buying is worth it or not
right
and so Samsung sent us all reviewers
this Galaxy Note 20 Ultra which is
really really great phone for 1300 bucks
and so we're all out since we have it
early we're all testing and
enthusiastically giving this phone a
shot but none of us as far as I know
have the note 20 which is the thousand
dollar
plastic 1080p 60 hertz in my opinion
severely overpriced phone none of us are
out enthusiastically testing and
reviewing that one PSA that's probably
on purpose so note 20 Ultra is 1300
bucks if you can swing it great if
you're looking for something similar but
looking to save a bit of money I would
actually hold off on trying to just go
straight to the note 20 for now I would
wait for some reviews of that at least
or maybe look to some other phones some
other Galaxy s20 Plus or even some
non-samsung phones because and this is a
new thought to have now in 2020 just
attaching the note name to something
doesn't necessarily mean
Flagship quality anymore like it used to
Becca from The Verge made a really great
point in her video about Samsung's
lineup which is the word you used to
look for to symbolize and describe the
absolute best in Samsung's lineup used
to be
node
but it's not
now the word you need to look for
is ultra the ultra
it's a nice phone yeah
but for thirteen hundred bucks
it better be
that's been it thanks for watching catch
you guys in the next one peace
[Music]